der yen fiel er durch seine reise
chinesische buch kennen und entdecken
sie die ältere früherer content dass das
wird so bleiben sie immer und auch mit
ihrem ort im alltag vom juni und stimmt
über landestypische gewohnheit
[Musik]
und am schluss vor der eisdiele vater
extra aus der schweiz angereist ist
das nicht für das ist die
[Musik]
großartige moment ist mein leben
dass ich es zurück zu den wurzeln 30 in
front
[Musik]
der bussard abriss im norden vom iran
ist viel mehr als er merkt er gehört zum
unesco weltkulturerbe
die räume sind stolz auf der
handelsplatz wurde siegerstraße eigenes
zimmer und ihrem engagement lohnt sich
von der sie bei ihrer cousine heimatland
aber zum ersten mal im iran
frauen sind
eine von der beliebte strecke von
bazaaria wo perserteppich knüpft
unverkauft wartezimmer unternehmen nun
im zentraliranischen kalte bier
real hat vom iran grund am bankschalter
oder bi und probiert es in der
wechselstube
müssen
[Musik]
ok
[Applaus]
der per 12
polizisten machen
sie kommen von hier
nächster versuch geldwechsel übergoss
steigende becker machen gibt's mal ob
wegen des drucks einer tanzgarde weil
ich ja auch die cousine zeigte bei der
gestus der schweiz die blaue moschee
zieht im 15 jahrhundert ein sich die
gläubigen zum gebet rufen mythische
sehenswürdigkeit für do liste
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
cousine hätte es ihm auf erzählt dass
sie und ihre familie gläubig sind und
fünfmal und dort bat ihn steckt die
letzte überraschung die fremde heimat
für zehn.de zusammen mit seiner frau
zuerst als heimatland renault als ihre
mutter juliana studie ziele habt immer
noch kanada wurde er in sachsen ist
ihrem heimatland wird sieht eine
besonders zeigen
[Gelächter]
ja klar
so werden wir dann auf englisch kit das
sind die füße oder aussieht und sie sind
typisch für die gegend aber total
typisch für die chinesische architektur
und sind bei diesem projekt vor davor
mussten
mit curry der waters zum unesco
weltkulturerbe
hallo
die füße sind über generationen vererbt
worden und gießen die familie lapid
immenhof dem land die spitze spezielles
museum verschwitzt standen nicht das
nötige meisten gefolgt
[Musik]
aber da hat durch öffentlich zugänglich
es hat einfach quasi zwei welt was wir
jetzt sehen oder so
hier ist auch sehr ländlich und ja immer
noch sehr stark auf landwirtschaft
passiert oder und so ist meine mutter
aufgewachsen und so dass dass es dann
richtig wichtig für mich auch dass ich
das sehe und nicht nur autos der
hunderttausendste hochhauser sich
gesehen habe ist es wichtig wie sie
aufgewachsen ist ausland und das freut
mich dass ich das auch erleben darf mit
4 3 sieg sagte jens sieht das alles zum
heer stimmung
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hydro mit die eltern der vater damit ist
ihre und an dieser theorie zugewandert
euro die sie wenn sie mal die fremde
heimat endlich kennenlernen
[Musik]
so gut sitzt du uns ist
sie macht ihre worte die sie in der
muttersprache begrüßt
man sieht schon wirklich geht ist die
wahl
doch
und ja aber das ist doch schon gut für
die mannschaft ist das sehr wichtig ist
eine emotionale moment wären ein jahr
nach und und tochter im land geborene
strafe zahlen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
insider haben
mein name vorsprung
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
was ich fühle könnte kann ich nicht
ausgebildet das ist die große moment ist
für mein leben
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
die dann dorf im süden chinas am jenzig
materialien aufgewachsen
die jens ist der spalter mitte bis in
der schwester und der bruder von emc
muss was damals schien ob sie sind
dagegen tradition dass mein freund die
vier leichen fort mit dem editor womit
vorfahrer vom besuch wert
[Musik]
oh mann
vollkommen egal denn für falschgeld
wovor fahrig und brauche zum sicher bis
im jenseits kaufe ich sehe speziellen
eigentlich schön also das ist ja das ist
das erste mal dass ich das gemacht habe
es ist ganz speziell
[Musik]
ganz ehrlich zustande wo die chemie
herstellers jahr verbrachte sie jobkrise
worte wo man das stausee baute
tschechien ist denn los ging's
[Musik]
das war eigentlich auf der seite eines
tages haben sie gesagt ja das ist okay
[Musik]
aus schweizerin haben sich gar nicht
vorstellen
und wird man auf barrikaden wir haben
das who's who serbin mehrere
generationen der familie ist und erkennt
und pflegt wird und wenn da was passiert
ich glaube es wird passieren
[Musik]
timo und die familie verließ und vor ort
wurde madschid viel schönere betreut
schöne ferien war das einfach blieb
ob sie die see das war wirklich tolle
zeit in und was fordern weißt du dass
klar dass wasser und vorhaben genossen
man hat so kabinen gemacht gehabt waren
viele kabinen für umzug und ziel morgen
sind wir gegangen abend wieder zurück
aber der urania sehe die letzten 40
jahre verbracht verloren
seit weniger wasser und rietheim ii
nehmen
[Musik]
dazwischen geht noch ja aber es gibt
ecken wie sie mengen geplatzten und
saison extrem zu dem recht genau
[Musik]
ich bin überrascht wie und jetzt kommt
noch dass vielleicht mal ganz viel glück
sich rabatte tee und ausgeschlossen
aber die leute die haben wir hier
größtes leute gehabt wir haben genossen
die sonne zeit so viele leute waren sich
hier
[Musik]
dass er wie das spielglück bank ist es
ist schlechterdings land mehr angesagt
in ordnung es ist ich bin immer wenn
jedes mal wenn ich hier komme überhaupt
allgemeinen archiven von einer seite ist
es sehr große freude
und irgendwann dann bedrückt mich später
[Musik]
der yen 710 die familie fahrer des baur
kilometer vitalinus music store schmidt
das bad nutzen die wunder dass sie vater
aufgewachsen
am lenzin l trennt sich trennt wunder
noch liegt der vater wohnt wieder
familie immer nutzt corner da die ganze
war es nicht viel über ihn und sie in
die vergangenheit und ihre morde von
sammers wildermuth klappt wie ich
aufgewachsen bin
erst am arbeiten aber jetzt auch nicht
so wahnsinnig gut mit meiner mutter das
auf ist der ist nicht gekommen oder
wirklich nur einmal im jahr an einem
nachmittag in seinen restaurants und
schwarze kreuz mit ihm oder nicht so
wahnsinnig gutes verhältnis kann nicht
nur kann ich nur lernen davon oder sich
zu sehen woher jetzt woher sie kommen
gekommen sind und wieso sie vielleicht
jetzt so sind oder ich weiß ja weiß es
nicht sondern entwickeln ihre zukunft
oder vergangenheit das bevor
[Gelächter]
dankbar dass wir in so eine
fortgeschrittene land geboren auf
wachstum
aber es ist gut dass wir es gesehen habe
[Musik]
noch eine woche dort das neue ryse im
iran langsam zu ihrem vater wird ihre
hütten spezieller ort zeigen einen
schicksalhaften moment erinnert in paris
hätte matschie 1984 mit seinen freunden
die bestandene matura prüfung haben
bestanden
und ich habe mich meine freunde
[Musik]
logitech motorrad zwar mit bravour
bestanden aber will arme von alten sitz
in zukunft nicht rosig aussehen
[Musik]
ich hab gewusst
ich kann nicht studien
[Musik]
ich möchte
die fina finanziellen lage war überhaupt
nicht gut
überhaupt nicht aber dann passiert
dieses wunder ein professor meldet sich
beim budget und seitdem rms stipendium
über zum studieren
meine schicksal hat da angefangen
die haben mir gesagt du ist gewählt
worden nach deutschland gehen ich habe
die beste prüfung gemacht und das war
moment
die schönsten momente meines lebens wie
bei vw nach deutschland er hat er
mehrere morgen
und diese familie wird nicht existent zu
sagen diese dass sie mutig finger vom in
party das anders schreiben das an der
kultur eine grenze sprache nicht so gut
kennt hat und ich glaube ja damit also
die extrem stolz
[Musik]
im süden chinas jens korn oder
ausgewandert sind im dorf erinnert sich
noch gut
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich bin sonst kein instrument das ich
noch eher gut um programme you can ja
geil eine gratisaktion und erzählt auch
wie sie vorher gestellt haben und so
fort
im dorf gehört und er hat sein wird
der freund von weitere geschichten auf
lager
[Musik]
mein vater hat dem mann gezeigt wie man
schreibt oder war es das eingefordert
mit vornamen zu mir kommen und und
wollen wir das zeigen und erzählen oder
es ist gold wert sein
was sicher bauen in letzter zeit habe
oder so aber alle reden so sehr mein
vater deshalb aussagen es so eine gute
mensch und ist erich und arbeitet viel
und ja
[Musik]
ich kenne einfach diese geschichte nun
meine fahrt nicht
sie wurde bereits bewusst wie wenig
aggressiv und wie viele titel verpasst
hat
[Musik]
ich freue mich das nächste mal lasse ich
dann eben besuchen kann dass wir dann
wieder etwas das das dass das dorf
wieder sprechen kann und alle können und
und seine kollegen die ich kennengelernt
habe noch drüber schwarzen und co
[Musik]
haim omer eleganz verwandtschaft seiner
das mal und sich zu verabschieden
[Musik]
langsam wird mir bewusst dass man tick
zu weit und dem iran eine große familie
zurück 100 gefühl her und ich weiß dass
die verbindung wird bleiben
das weiß ich und ich bin glücklich
darüber
der satirische verschiedene jahr
gegangen wie jetzt ihre tochter und ihre
wahnsinns tor familie kapitel ihrer
familie zudem einfach positiv
[Musik]
und sich auch nicht
im ersten moment taxis sind familien das
ist eigentlich immer nach stark dank
rang sechs richtige und erklärt wie man
sich oft ob ich sie ist auch das sekret
im moment laufe es wird daher immer
gesagt
erst einmal aber auch das was unter dem
motto für das war ich
[Musik]
im iran gibt es zum abschied des als
ritual stand unter dem koran sure das
bringt glück glück für kreis und glück
fürs leben
[Musik]
interface oder fast eine mission
trug in china
am letzten tag von jens innere reis
viertes großes fest für ihn die mutter
gm hat mehr als 200 verwandte und
bekannte klodt
[Musik]
ich
[Applaus]
ich blicke wartet mehr bewältigt
[Musik]
es ist die geschichte dieses interview
vor dem großen fahrspaß absurd madonna
und bringt ihnen als offen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die ganz familie vom ing renault vereint
nur sofort teil ist kommt ab liebe will
muss schon auch gefragt wieso er nicht
da ist
[Musik]
meine
es ist wie eine familie wohnen hier hoch
nach unrechts das ist so viele gekommen
sind und gross tat dabei nicht nur
menschen nichts nichts besonderes
sondern das ja auch so ein großes
angekommen sind und mache seine neue
[Musik]
position zu eigen
das ist da eben wichtig ist dann dass
sich dann doch einmal
und natürlich darf der hotelgäste
beitrag zur unterhaltung leisten
[Musik]
hier raus
2 str ich riesig musste ganze region
sind verwandt die und freunden angereist
sind rückkehr vor ihrem sohn jens i und
sie in der familie
unglaublich das ist dass wir das so
etwas erleben darf
und wer weiß wann entschieden wird
wir machen etwas geschieht ist raus
da mache ich platt ich bin so froh dass
wir das wir gesehen haben dass das virus
und der herzen und bleiben
ja wenn die ganze familie nicht
wir können mit wem begangen zwischen
den schwarzen weg dass ich wenn ich mich
an alle reisen com planen und ich glaube
da macht einfach sehr viel bedeutet x100
ich habe viel gelernt familie sehr
wichtig
ja
[Musik]
wer hast du sonst
vergangenheit verarbeiten frage bern tut
sich selber neu trainieren 30 die front
heimat für andere das level wie möglich
mit einem turnschuh bonds land züchtet
das 1.000 teilnehmer erwartet
[Musik]